you're fine you're fine
you always use a condom so you're fine
hey dude i've got this thing
if a young woman needs a procedure is
that possible
where's the closest facility there's an
albuquerque in missouri
the law won't let me get one without my
parents knowing
[Music]
i know we're not close anymore true and
i'm the last person that you want to
help
accurate but i need your help and i
don't have anywhere else to go go
where to get the thing the the procedure
so you're hiding this from your man
your best friend hey girl and your jesus
freak parents and you thought
why not ask bailey butler to drive me
hundreds of miles cause she probably
doesn't have anything to do anyway
kind of yes bailey bailey come on
i'm just messing with you you're right i
do not have anything going on
i thought you drove a camry
oklahoma texas new mexico
we'll be in albuquerque by tomorrow
night no
and we'll be home sunday evening
i'm setting the alarm for 5 a.m
self-care huh i had to post something so
people wouldn't bother me of course so
people wouldn't know you're with me
we both know you wouldn't do the same
for me you made it really hard to be
your friend
i'm sorry that i couldn't be perfect for
you all the time i needed you to be
perfect
i appreciate everything you've done for
me
you crazy idiot that is so goddamn nice
let's go cut them
in the bathroom
[Music]
why are they looking at the car i see my
mom's boyfriend's car we're driving a
stolen car
hello if you don't help us out we're
gonna be in so much trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think that this is what you
really want it's my life it's my choice
trees go fast
you